One thing I've noticed after talking to my closest friends
is how they keep saying how I've changed
At first that kind of threw me off
but when I started thinking about it
it's actually a compliment
in fact I love that they've noticed
which has made me reflect a little on the inner work that I've been doing
I've completely rewired the way I think,
how I operate,
I've changed my living,
I've even changed my identity
so here are the things that I've done to change my life for the positive
Before I always felt like I struggled with self sabotage
I was toxic and unhappy
and it made me feel like I was living the life that I didn't deserve
so here's some of the things that I wish I worked on sooner
number one establishing routine
your inner self loves routine
okay it's good
and it makes you feel stable
this will help build stability
and it'll make you feel safe
and obviously
everyday brings on new obstacles
but building a firm routine will help put your mind at ease
your inner routine will just take over
like do you shower in the morning or in the evening
what are you gonna prepare for dinner
if you have a routine
and you find what works for you
you don't have to think about it because you built that routine
No.2 journaling
journaling has been huge to help with my anxiety and stress
basically I can just brain dump everything
that's on my mind
and put it to paper so it's not stuck in my head
this helps me get things off my mind
and it also helps me not brain dump on friends or family members
this allows me to process my own thoughts through journaling
now I don't journal every single day
but for the most part when I do
I've noticed a big change in my mind
and the way I can function throughout the day
basically when I put my thoughts on paper
my brain feels less busy
being self aware is so
so important
if you wanna see self growth and improvement
No. 3 therapy
I know you're probably like oh geez
therapy not for me
and I understand
I've tried multiple therapist
but you have to find the one that works for you
you may think it's a waste of time
but truly if you find the right therapist that works for you
that's when you see real growth
it takes trial and error
not every therapist or person are you gonna click with
and as exhausting as that sounds
if you wanna see real improvement of your life
it's gonna take work
this will help you get over your own roadblocks
and help heal your inner trauma
No. 4 letting go of friends or bad habits that do not serve you
let go of people that aren't good for you
and I know it's hard
but you just have to
if you wanna improve
the version of yourself
you have to have to let go of the people that do not make you better
the people you surround yourself with is very important
because you become the people who you surround yourself with
maybe you have a friend
a fun friend
who parties and doesn't take life seriously
you gotta let them go
if you don't wanna continue down that path honestly
you have to protect your peace
and your future selves peace
I know it's hard
but real growth
and changing old habits is hard
it's gonna be hard
let go of the bad,
to let the good into your life,
that's essential for living the best version of your life
so reflect on these things
if you want to live the life you deserve
and I'm curious
do you do any of these things?
or what do you do?